as promised let's do a couple of simple
snell's law examples so let's say
let's say that i have
let's say that i have two
two media i guess plural of mediums so
let's say i have air right here
air and then right here is the surface
that is the surface let me do that in a
more appropriate color that is the
surface of the water
so this right here is the surface of
water and i know that i have a light ray
i have a light ray
coming in
with an incident angle of
so it has an incident angle so relative
to the perpendicular it has an incident
angle of
of 35
degrees and what i want to know is i
want to know what the angle of
refraction will be
so it will refract a little bit it will
bend inwards a little bit since this
outside is going to be in the air a
little longer if you
buy into my car traveling to into the
mud analogy so it will then
bend a little bit and i want to figure
out what this new angle will be i want
to figure out the angle of refraction
i'll call that theta 2
what is this and so we can just this is
just straight up applying snell's law
and i'm going to use the version with
the
using the refraction indices since we
have a table here from the ck12.org
flexbook on the refraction indices and
you can go get it for free if you like
and that just tells us
that just tells us that there are
fraction index for the first medium so
that is air the fraction index for air
times the sine
of the incident angle in this case it's
35 degrees
is going to be equal to the refraction
index for water
index for water times the sine of this
angle right over here times
the sine of theta two and we know what
the refraction index for air and for
water is then we just have to solve for
theta two so let's just do that the
refraction index for error is
this number right over here 1.00029
so it's going to be 1.00
there's only there's three zeros 1.00029
times the sine of 35 degrees is going to
be equal to the refraction index for
water which is 1.33
so it's
1.33 times sine
times sine of theta two now we can
divide both sides of this equation by
one point three three
we divide one both sides by one point
three three on this side we're just left
with sine of theta two on the left hand
side let's get our calculator out for
this
so let me get
the handy calculator
and so we want to calculate and i made
sure my calculator is in degree mode
1.00029
times
the sine of 35 degrees so that's the
numerator of this expression right here
the green part that's 0.5737
divided by
1.33 i'm just dividing by the numerator
here this when you just do a divide this
answer it means your last answer that's
the numerator up here divided by that
denominator and so i get
.4314 i'll just round a little bit
so i'll get so i get i'll switch colors
0.4314
is equal to sine
of theta 2. and now to solve for theta
you just have to take the inverse sine
of both sides of this so you get the
inverse so you could get the inverse
sine this doesn't mean sine to the
negative one you could also do this the
arc sine the sine inverse of 0.4314
is going to be equal to the inverse sine
of sine is just the angle itself or i
guess when we're dealing with uh when
we're dealing with angles in a in a
normal range it's going to be the angle
itself and that's going to be the case
with this right over here and if any of
that is confusing
you might want to review the videos on
the inverse sine and the inverse cosine
and they're in the trigonometry playlist
but we can very easily figure out the
inverse sine for this right over here
you literally you have sine here the
when you press second you get the
inverse sine so it's the inverse sine or
the arc sine of that number right over
there and instead of retyping it i can
just put second and then answer so i'm
taking the inverse sine of that number
so that's exactly
that's exactly what i'm doing right over
here and that will give me an angle that
will give me an angle
and i get
25.55 we're all around it 25.6
degrees
so this theta 2
theta 2
theta 2 is equal to 25
maybe i'll say approximately equal to
some
25.6 degrees so snell's law goes with
our little car driving into the mud
analogy it's going to be a narrow degree
it's going to come inwards a little bit
closer to vertical and theta 2 is equal
to 25.6
degrees and you could do the other way
let's say let's do another example
let's say
let's say that we have
just to make just to make things
simpler
let's say that i have some surface right
over here so this is some unknown
material and we're traveling in space
we're on the space shuttle and so this
is a vacuum
this is a vacuum right over here or
pretty darn close to a vacuum and i have
light coming in at some angle
i have light coming in at some angle
just like that let me draw a drop of
vertical
so
it's coming in at some angle actually
let me make it interesting let me make
the light go from the slower medium to
the faster medium just because the last
time we went from the faster the slower
so it's in a vacuum so let's say i have
some light let's have some light
traveling
traveling like this
and once again though if you view the
just to get the the get of whether it's
going to bend inward or bend outward the
left side is going to get out first it's
going to travel first it's going to it's
going to travel faster first so it will
bend inwards when it goes into the
faster material so this is some unknown
this is some unknown material where
light travels slower
and
let's say we were able to measure let's
say we're able to measure the angles
let's let me drop a vertical right here
let me drop a vertical right over here
and so let's say that this right here
that right there is
let's say that this right here is 30
degrees and let's say we're able to
measure the angle of refraction and the
angle of refraction over here is
let's say that this is 40 degrees
so given that we're able to measure the
incident angle and the angle of
refraction can we figure out the
refraction index for this material or
even better can we figure out the speed
of light in that material so let's
figure out the refraction index first
so the refraction index
so we know the refraction index for this
questionable material times the sine
of 30 degrees is going to be equal to
the refraction index for vacuum well
that's just the ratio of the speed of
light in the vacuum to the speed of
light in the vacuum so this is going to
be one so it's going to be one that's
the this is the same thing as n for a
vacuum and i'll just write a 1 there
times the sine of 40 degrees
times the sine of 40 degrees or if we
wanted to solve for this unknown
refraction index we just divide both
sides of the equation by sine of 30. so
our unknown refraction index is going to
be this is just the sine of 40 degrees
sine of 40 degrees over this over the
sine of 30 degrees
over the sine of 30 degrees so we can
get our handy calculator out and so we
have
we have the sine of 40
sine of 40 divided by the sine
sine of 30 degrees
make sure you're in degree mode if you
try this and you get one point let's
just round it 1.29
so this is approximately equal to
so our unknown refraction index for our
material
is equal to
1.29 so we're able to figure out the
unknown refract the unknown refraction
index and we can actually use this to
figure out the velocity of light in this
material because remember this unknown
this unknown refraction index is equal
to the velocity of light in a vacuum
which is 300 million meters per second
divided by the velocity in this material
the unknown material so we know that
1.29
is equal to the velocity of light in a
vacuum so we could write 300
million
300 million meters per second divided by
the unknown velocity in this material
i'll put a question mark and so we can
multiply both sides times our unknown
velocity i'm running out of space or we
have other stuff written over here so i
could multiply both sides by this v
and i'll get
1.29 times this v with a question mark
is going to be equal to 300
300 million
meters per second and i can divide both
sides by 1.29
the question mark is going to be this
whole thing 300 million
300 million divided by
1.29
or another way to think of it is light
travels 1.29 times faster in a vacuum
than it does in this material right over
here but let's figure out its velocity
so in this material light will travel a
slow so that's 300
300 million
divided by 1.29
light will travel a super slow 232
million
meters per second so this is
approximately
this is approximately just to round off
so it's approximately 232
million
meters per second if we had to guess
what this material is let's see i just
made up these numbers but let's see if
there's something that has a refraction
index close to 1.29 so it's pretty close
to 1.29 here so maybe this is some type
of interface with water in a vacuum
where the water somehow isn't actually
evaporating because of the lack of
pressure or maybe some other material
let's keep it that way something that
wouldn't maybe some type of solid
material but anyway those were hopefully
two fairly straightforward snell's law
problems in the next video i'll do a
slightly more involved one